i've always felt like my life could be a  reality tv show already know i'm dating  angry reactions but like there's so much  more crazy stuff that goes on in my life  okay first crazy thing is i have nine  siblings i've always joked that i'd call  us the down-to-earth ginger kardashians  because there's just so many of us and  we're always up to something new another  crazy thing is my dad literally bought a  waterslide and put it up in our backyard  we'll go on trips as a family and do  crazy things like ice climbing skiing  whatever and if you saw this video  you'll know we live in the super big  super creative and super organized house  and everyone has their own personality  and there's so so much more so comment  below if you want to know who the  characters would be in my reality tv  show